[Music]
and supermarkets sleepover news was bad
Oh that'd be so cool okay Black Friday
sounds really fun unlimited snacks
submitted by $0.49
mm-hmm Jeffrey's not fitty cent why
that's an old-ass reference
no one knows fit his head maybe maybe
he's like our generation and he made
that joke I know I had someone come up
to me at a vegetarian restaurant that I
would never think was a fan and she was
like one of the Chinese waitresses no it
was just a random place and she was a
suspended Grady that does not look like
she even advocates the internet at all
the middle aged like 38 42 she's
probably watching right now like what is
this person supposed to look like just a
nerd all I'm saying is that all of our
friends come in different shapes and
forms and backgrounds and I think the
cool usually asian young asian but
whenever I see something differently
that's [ __ ] cool
remember like the the guy that asked for
David he told me as hell David it was
like this white guy kind of like need
30s 40s me I feel like the air drums you
guys like the farmer tan you there is
there's not really not funny in real
life I was like holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
awesome I [ __ ] love you made my whole
dirty dick you love them huh I do too
kids were locked in a supermarket
overnight and managed to eat an ungodly
amount of food I don't want to pay for
it at the end but that's ones kids in 13
year old that's a dream for that age
holy [ __ ] first of all dancing so no
parents decided to no I want to know
what the heck where did the parents work
so I don't know there's no info about
like my pet might my child is missing
mm-hmm or maybe they texted her mom dad
don't worry man we're safe or maybe
they're sleeping over each other yeah
that kind of drugged me so this sounds
like it's the perspective of the
supermarket then we're probably gonna
get the supermarket details probably
America Scotland what kind of snacks do
they have there so he's two kids they
were found around 2:00 a.m. in a
Stansbury's superstore
that's not California oh the pants
probably called if they were found at
2:00 a.m. yeah see I want to know how
wait I wasn't listening where was this
Scotland sorry I was like sorry I was
killing a fruit fly yeah so so
apparently they were found when the
morning the early morning workers showed
up that's me so not it's wait oh but
it's you a holy morning god damn Michele
pellet early yeah I guess like if the
store open mic around freaking them in
again and they had this talk before damn
I don't a graveyard shift at Babies R Us
and you gotta get there at 2:00 a.m. I
forgot what do you receive like delivery
what did you do yeah well there was a
shipping department that they receive
deliveries by was the one that was
taught the floor so we would be there
like in the middle of the night when
there's nothing just organizing
everything for the next day yeah at
least you didn't have to deal with
[ __ ] so hey do they with people
mm-hmm
I remember when I worked that tarush a
mmm I was a cart boy and just because I
had a uniform on they will always ask me
questions excuse me where's the lush and
that was this that was bad and I'm all
like [ __ ] I just started working here
let me get somebody to help
I'll give you had a smoker voice before
and in one day they needed help on the
register
they [ __ ] barely taught me how to
work that [ __ ] so I just started doing
this [ __ ] and I'm all like oh cool and
I'm all trying to act all professional
and his lady's like be a light Norah
Jones and she was all looking at me like
why like why are you looking at my [ __ ]
am I
[ __ ] you that is we could don't look at
my [ __ ] I remember working as a hostess
at the Cheesecake Factory
Glendale Americana oh they always ask
people so you want to sit inside or
outside I don't know what's it like
outside [ __ ] where the [ __ ] did you
guys come from where did you teleport in
here [ __ ] I've been in here for six
hours how you gonna ask me what the [ __ ]
back outside [ __ ] hate you just came
from there yeah I'm just like no I would
legit because my boss is really cool I'm
like I don't know I've been inside all
day well how's the inside like there
yeah right like the inside I can tell
you everything about the [ __ ] inside
the outside wall you guys might have
been through sunny weather but our
outside is actually rainy right now so
go ahead enjoy the [ __ ] the monsoon
you're gonna need snow jackets my bosses
were great I got to be kind of a
smartass awesome you like their sport
chalet right next door make sure to get
a heavy jacket get a [ __ ] Park a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] idiot it's July and
then I had one lady I know so she came
back and you say I want to sit outside
oh why there's bugs and birds and it's
too hot I'm like outside oh my god no
way holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
really there's birds chirping you
wouldn't say this one's oh no Mike why
didn't you tell me the Sun was out there
no it's hot the roof is missing maybe my
favorite is one like dirty walls really
no walls during mother's day when it's
like super busy oh no it's always these
[ __ ] that don't make reservations and
then I tell them I started the weights
like about an hour and a half okay we'll
wait and then five minutes of come I've
been waiting two hours they're Armenians
I just [ __ ] convert it's Glendale
I've been waiting two hours and then
like I have a computer that shows me
when the [ __ ] you came in how long you
been waiting what's your [ __ ] name is
so I can be a smartass I'm like actually
over here is your name
you've been waiting for five minutes
when I told you an hour and a half
there's like that's why I never lasted
in customer service it's difficult
imagine dealing with these two little
boys so what they days dope yeah the
dream that the clothes store the clothes
oh my god
sorry so the store closed at 10:00 a.m.
at 10:00 p.m. and they weren't caught
until 2:00 and so they had a full four
hours they're just eating wherever the
[ __ ] they want and they were drinking
alcohol oh [ __ ] you little mischievous
[ __ ] better pay for that okay
what is the drinking age younger there I
don't think it's 11 or 10 I don't know
every country is different okay steam
might be I might be believable I would
take because you know I think that is
the legal age if you're under parental
supervision but like I don't know if
like 12 and 13 is legal any country
agent in certain Alabama is like 16
hey I just remember hearing a story a
long long time ago I don't know for what
country but a 13 year old is able to buy
alcohol that's why I'm saying oh yeah
you could mean by it but consuming it is
different because I know in Asia kids
buy alcohol and cigarettes for their
parents in a day they go pick it up how
do they know but make sure they don't
[ __ ] consume it this is a different
culture yeah but there's little kids in
Europe to just buying wine for their
parents may be so cool it's free but I
go pick up the bottle of wine and some
cheese for daddy you know what I found
interesting too and Barcelona they have
the these like vending machines for
cigarettes because we were in the lobby
area of our hotel and we observe some
couple they were asking the people at
the front desk to unlock the machine for
them to be able to buy cigarettes from
the vending machine and then I asked
I'm like oh why do you need to do that
because he pulled out like a remote and
then he went like aah and then he was
like oh it's a law and you know that
place or that so he ended up saying that
there was a law that they have that
implemented in all the machining so kids
can't buy it it wasn't interesting you
know we use that many machines out here
cigarette vending machines
I remember Danny's like everywhere when
I was a little boy and it was like one
of those ones will you pull a pen or
something in it on a pack put pops up
yeah boys they ended up consuming almost
four hundred dollars worth of goods
maybe open it took a few bites and
ultimately won yeah yeah they had a buff
it in the way they got away the way that
they were able to spend the night there
was because they were hiding the clothes
I don't perfect yeah you were hiding
like near the loading area in between
like the racks so they waited until the
door the store closed and then that's
when they ended up these guys are
[ __ ] troublemakers hmm no wonder
their parents aren't looking from there
like thank God they ran away apparently
gone we can bone at home [ __ ] it this
sounds like a TV show or movie cuz I
remember I got what I watched but the
kids they decided to stay at light in
this camping setup and like a sports
touring at the mall and then when the
mall shut down Disney movie got out I
forgot what it was and they just [ __ ]
had a blast at the mall yeah I remember
seeing that saw work [ __ ] all the
plaster was it closed the how to do that
so did their appearance that's a pig or
did they have to do anything that's a
good question I don't know all they
mentioned is that the parents were
called over I would say they picked up
their kids and I would say if you he has
to come here and work every day until
your bill is done or else we're gonna
take you to jail one of my favorite
things to do is to explore 24-hour
Walmart at night yes yeah yeah yeah
those are super fun especially people
watching you think oh man I remember
this one time if someone's watching you
because you look interesting it's fine
we're all there for a reason man just
watching people this is one couple that
I had ran into it like it was
for go-go dancing in Orange County mr.
24-hour Walmart I was with my best
friend and I was waiting in line and
there was a Vietnamese guy and this
Vietnamese girl who so imagine what I'm
wearing a long dress and her platform
heels like from the 90s why she just
looked like she was like yeah and she
talked like and she smoked for you to
meet my girlfriend didn't understand so
but I understood and then she was like
in Vietnamese she's like I mean he's
like oh my god that's so good sweetheart
you're such a good girl she spoke like
that she's so pretty right you're so
good like that's amazing you did that
all by yourself and this chick look like
she was like 29 30
it was weirdest [ __ ] yeah she left I
told my friend was going on I was like
dude that [ __ ] was [ __ ] out of it it
was weird he talked early he was a
little she was a little girl what works
awesome at night yeah sex trafficking
victim or something hmm
or she's just not a lot of drugs yeah
I'll think of the latter mm-hmm she
talks like I'm just gonna stay away from
Walmart hey guys would you think of that
video I know you loved it so make sure
to hit that like button to watch more
videos and check it out up here
[Music]
you